c'est pas possible j'en peux plus une
femme trans en MMA a explosé une autre
femme je précise que j'ai absolument
rien contre les personnes trans chacun
fait ce qu'il veut mais quand on mélange
sport de compétition et trans c'est pas
normal cette femme trans c'est un ancien
mec des forces spéciales et même si
aujourd'hui c'est une femme il a une
masse musculaire et un taux testostérone
bien supérieur à celui d'une femme c'est
donc pas normal qui se battent contre
une femme c'est pour ça qu'il y a des
catégories dans le sport homme femme ce
n'est pas être sexiste mais juste être
logique ça ne sert pas du tout la cause
des femmes qu'on autorise des femmes
trans à concourir contre elle une
personne trans aura clairement un
avantage physique c'est donc injuste
pour ses athlètes féminines et pour le
sport alors ça c'est le débat qui était
posé ça c'est pour ça fait ça fait rire
la vérité alors le convoi en question on
va regarder un petit bout bah c'est vrai
qu'il y a une différence on regarde on
parle juste après mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas très équilibré
voilà alors Gilles qu'en est-il dans la
législation autour des sports de combat
et des sports en général ils posent une
vraie question quand même qui est
pertinente puisqu'il faut savoir en
France par exemple il y a que la
fédération de rugby à 15 qui autorise
des joueuses transgenres si elles ont
suivi un traitement hormonal pendant 12
mois sinon c'est interdit et
l'athlétisme au niveau mondial on est en
pleine actu vient d'interdire à des
personnes transgenres de disputer des
compétitions féminines c'est une vraie
question c'est pas du tout une question
c'est plutôt du sexisme absolument pas
de la transphobie du tout c'est un
simplement un débat sur y a-t-il une
équité sportive il y avait la fameuse
athlète africaine du Sud Semenya qui
concourrait en athlétisme et dont tous
ces concurrentes disaient mais elle est
favorisée par rapport à nous et elle ne
pouvait courir d'ailleurs qu'à partir du
400 mètres exactement avec un suivi très
précis du taux de testostérone donc un
vrai débat je trouve que alors peut-être
un peu maladroitement mais il pose une
vraie question de l'équitesse sportive
après si on inverse le propos ce qui
décident de devenir homme qui sont
femmes qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour eux
parce que pour le coup ils saute des
avantages alors là la personne qui a
rien et la question se pose moi
évidemment vous l'avez dit parce que il
y a moins un problème d'équité ou
d'iniquité ils sont désavantagés et donc
c'est un vrai problème et la natation
aux États-Unis il y a une nageuse qui a
tout raflé voilà et donc ça a fait un
vrai débat parce que les concurrents
t'ont dit mais c'est une personne
transgenre donc nous on peut pas
concourir contre et aux États et
maintenant la natation va créer une
catégorie des personnes transgenres ce
qui est bizarre aussi parce qu'ils vont
pas concourir tout seul dans leur coin
mais c'est un vrai débat qui se pose
actuellement dans le sport de haut
niveau et donc l'athlétisme maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on a décidé il y a les
personnes transgenres la possibilité mal
parce que c'est banni les personnes
transgenres sont bannis des compétitions
féminines d'athlétisme ça a été décidé
hier
qui ça choque je pense qu'on pourrait
partir du principe que toutes les femmes
n'ont pas la même force si demain je me
bats avec Daniel il y a déjà
une différence
par rapport
donc de toute manière quoi qu'il arrive
on peut aussi partir du principe que
toutes les femmes n'ont pas la même
force que c'est femme là elles prennent
des bloqueurs tout au long de leur tour
si demain moi je décide de devenir une
femme je me fais un match de box avec
vous ça va durer deux secondes parce que
non pas de photos qui ont fait que ton
taux de testostérone parce qu'en fait
précise quand même de la force physique
également la force physique de de
l'homme sans dire parce qu'on rentre
toujours dans les débats la femme plus
faible mais la force physique de
Benjamin entre guillemets et déjà en
place donc même si on fera oui
que ces personnes prennent tout au long
tout à fait vrai par rapport au bloqueur
il y a le débat les personnes
[Musique]
on est d'accord
si on boxer par exemple la même
catégorie il y a des catégories exprès
de poids et tout ça bien
une catégorie spécialiste pour
l'étranger et dans ce cas-là il y aurait
plus de débat il y aurait plus de
problème
quasiment seul
si demain on dit voilà bah maintenant il
y a pas de raison puisqu'on a reconnu
l'existence en tant que femme d'une
personne transgenre on doit le laisser
participer à des compétitions
bah il y avait l'athlète moi j'ai suivi
tout le parcours de cette fameuse
athlète sud-africaine c'est Menia et qui
qui elle disait mais moi j'ai laissé moi
courir laissez-moi courir c'est très
particulier moi je pense quand même
qu'il y a une iniquité bien sûr pourtant
je suis souvent pour l'inclusion totale
mais là je pense que ces femmes
favoriser pour des raisons
physiologiques
citer l’exemple aussi des des de
handisport est-ce que c'est un bon
exemple où il est à côté de la plaque en
disant voilà on fait bien des
compétitions handisport dans toutes les
catégories d'ailleurs il y a des
problèmes il y a des problèmes aussi et
les problèmes aussi d'ailleurs ce qui
court avec des lames pour quasiment plus
vite que ceux qui consomme c'est vrai et
ce qui va se poser aussi après c'est
parce que vous savez on parle on parle
du dopage vous savez il y en a beaucoup
qui prennent la testostérone par exemple
pour différents sports là c'est pareil
les taux est-ce que est-ce que ça va
être vu comme du dopage est-ce que c'est
il y a tout qui rentre c'est c'est un
sujet complexe je pense qu'il faudrait
faire des catégories
de sportif de haut niveau ça dure pas
très longtemps c'était 30 ans et elle
peut aussi décider de faire leur
transformation après leur carrière de
Sporting
tu remets en arrière